[Musique]
l exode nuit pour vous ne sont pas
arrêtés à hollywood vous avez été arrêté
il ya deux ans pour vos relations avec
une gamine de 14 ans qui elle n'avait
pas l'innocence de deux tests et il
paraît que vous risquez 50 ans de prison
alors où en êtes vous de cette affaire
ce qu'elle risque est difficile de finir
je risque maximum trois ans mais j'étais
en prison vous oubliez que jeter en
prison
trois mois et demi louis gt gt en fusion
un temps que qu'il apparaît manche
fallait être
c'est en sortant que j'ai appris que le
juge qui qui étaient dues qui est devenu
vedette grâce à cette ces affaires ne
voulait pas en terminer vous le maire m
contrairement à ce qu'il avait dit avant
que j'aille en prison je croyais que
c'était assez pour ça je quitter les
états unis
d'ailleurs le juge été enlevée elle de
cette affaire si je reviens aux états
unis ça serait un autre juge qui
s'occupera vous dites il revient aux
états unis mais pendant l'expérience de
la de la prison est ce que vous n'étiez
pas protéger un peu par votre nom
comment vous étiez vu par vous
mais tout ça c'était tout à fait le
contraire vous savez on s'en rend pas
compte que c'est la prison et surtout ce
que c'est à présent aux états unis le
juge qui qui qui envoie quelqu'un comme
moi en prison et est un homme
complètement innocent parce qu'il ne
sait pas que je risque ma vie pendant
chaque instant de mon séjour
justement parce que mon nom était connu
envoyé en prison la prison américaine
système pénitentiaire amis américains
est entièrement menée par des gangs de
gang différents comme
ce qu'on appelle mexique une mafia ou
bien déjà des aryens
enfin il ya plusieurs gangs les uns plus
puissants que les autres et pour
appartenir à un gant il faut faut se
montrer
il faut faire quelque chose chacun est à
la recherche de la publicité la
publicité la plus facile cd tu es
quelqu'un qui est connue vous savez
parce que si vous tuez quelqu'un qui est
anonyme ça n'a pas de retentissement
s'il ya quelqu'un qui a un qui a un nom
qui est dans la presse il est
immédiatement la proie de la prison qui
pendant six ans source de vécu avec la
peur moi je n'ai pas vécu d'un avec la
peur parce que les autorités de prison
m'ont foutu immédiatement dans un
secteur qui s'appelle secteur de la
protection spéciale c'est à dire vous
êtes constamment surveiller on peut pas
pratiquement on peut pas vous faire du
mal parce que vous êtes tout seul dans
votre cellule et à des portes d'acier
blindé qui sait faire vous n'avez pas
droit de sortir dans la cour
c'est doublement difficile mais au moins
vous vous risquez moins vous pensez que
vous resteriez à peu près 100 jours où
vous resteriez des années vous saviez
qui avaient une durée non je savais
qu'il y avait le maximum de 90 jours
vous voyez mais le système américain est
tout à fait différent du système de nos
systèmes européens
le juge vous condamne à une certaine
peine mais la durée est déterminée par
le système pénitentiaire
j'aurais pu rester 90 jours je savais
que c'était le maximum mais je compris
au bout d'une semaine que les autorités
de prison ne voulait pas que je reste
qu'ils savaient que j'appartiens parce
vous savez s'il n'y avait pas des gens
comme moi en prison j'étais avec dédé
des types qui ont tué 16 personnes vous
savez
il n'y avait pas un qui n'a pas tué
quelqu'un il voulait se débarrasser des
mois les plus vite possible la surprise
générale très vite après votre sortie de
prison vous avez disparu les états unis
des deux parties je sais pas si on peut
partir aussi facilement
les etats unis quand on est encore sous
le coude d'un jugement de la justice
est-ce que c'est aussi facile et d'autre
part on m'avait dit tout à l'heure si je
retourne aux états unis vous y retourner
je retournerai pas ce que je veux en
finir quand même avec cette affaire mais
je voulais partir parce qu'à ce moment
là je ne croyais pas que la justice
pourrait être faite
je croyais que j'étais plus de victimes
de 2,2 de certains une espèce de jeu qui
mène est le juge qui était discuté du ce
qualifier et si je partais pas il serait
jamais disqualifier ce jeu alors c'est à
dire que vous rentrerez pour que toutes
les choses soient claires même si elle
risque de retourner en prison à jeurre a
tourné un certain certainement mais ça
sera une autre atmosphère il y aura déjà
un peu de perspective les gens verront
toutes ces affaires dans une lumière
plus ou moins réalistes
vous parlez de la faire il faut rappeler
encore une fois qu'ils s'agissait de
relations un peu personnel avec une
fille de 14 ans mais quand vous l'avez
connu et pas seulement des
préoccupations morales y avait une base
qui était la réalité vaut votre
préférence pour les petites filles c'est
pas ma préférence pour le jeune fille
disons jeune femme se sent de mieux en
france
je n'ai jamais caché était toujours
entouré de jeunes filles et je dû
peut-être pas resté assez longtemps trop
longtemps aux états unis il faut pas
oublier que chacun qui a une relation
sexuelle avec une personne en dessous
des dix huit ans aux états unis est un
criminel
donc faut plus ou moins assumée que la
plupart de la population est en train de
commettre le crime plusieurs fois par
jour c'est la loi des états unis j'ai
suivant une loi gg je suis responsable
vous la péter le seul grands cinéastes
créateurs avoir eu des difficultés
même si c'est pour une autre raison
souvient de ce qui est arrivé mais c'est
pas en même chaque pas que je devais pas
seulement le cinéaste enfin ou alors
flynn non mais je n'étais pas le seul
je n'étais pas la seule personne avec
qui
cette fille avait des relations
sexuelles
elle a témoigné devant le grandiose et
avant que je sois d'inculpé et comme
vous le savez personne d'autre n'était
poursuivi est ce que des pays vous ne
pouvez pas aller aujourd'hui
enfin
que je peux aller partout en angleterre
en allemagne et crs que vous n'auriez
pas des histoires avec la justice ou la
police ou est ce que vous risquez je
vais vous faire arrêter et avec des
demandes d'extradition de la part des
deux communes les états unis peuvent
demander mon âme et mon extradition
sauf en france parce que vous êtes de
nationalité française ça en france sauf
des pays où le la relation sexuelle avec
une personne de 14 ans n'est pas un
crime et des pays comme ça existe et où
santé la libre de voyager en dehors de
la france
vous voulez tout vivait presque comme un
peu surveillés non non je ne me sens pas
du tout sauver pas pour le moment je me
sentirai [ __ ] mais peut-être mais
pendant les deux dernières années
c'était entièrement occupée par là la
réalisation de ces films je n'avais pas
j'avais pas le temps de dépenser au
voyage
[Musique]